[Music]
Hello, today I would like to talk about an interesting topic called scalable design to
improve work-life balance, which I was concerned about when switching to a platform.
Before the presentation, I will briefly introduce myself.
Yes, I am currently working in the e-commerce field.
This is Jeong-eun Lee, a web developer. The
next photo is one I took when I came in second place at JS Comp. It was
because of JS Comp that I experienced my first conference. I was able to meet a variety of people and
have good memories from that time, so I
was able to stand here. It was my
first time as a speaker.  I am very
nervous, but it
is an honor to be able to present at JS Comp Korea.
Why did I think about a scalable structure today?
What was the existing structure and
what problems were there? And the
scalable structure I designed to solve the problem.  And I would like to
introduce the benefits gained by the changed structure.
Why did we need a new design?
Could you please take a look at the following picture? What do you think is the situation? Is it
possible to add it within this specification schedule,
or would I like this feature to be omitted at this time as
work increases?  These are words you can hear a lot.
I've heard this a lot too.
In order to respond to these diversifying requirements, our code may be wrapped in rags and
advanced processing that is different from the original intention.
Why did our project have no choice but to respond in this way
?
Now, let's look at them one by one. The
first problem
was that the structure did not consider scalability at all.
First, this was the structure of my existing project. The
existing project
was implemented based on the presentational container pattern introduced by Dan Abramovu.
Initial service  At the time of provision, it
was not a very big feature, and the one-to-one implemented
components or communication structure
were not a big problem, but as the
functions increased and we now had a requirement to
provide services on a platform basis, we had
no choice but to face various problems.
First, there was a structural problem with the overall flow.
Since all business logic was implemented in the container component, it was
difficult to reuse the logic if the container was not used in the same way.
In the end, if the same function of a different UI was needed, a
new container was needed.  I
had no choice but to create an information code. It
is the same function to receive coupons as shown below, but as the modal provided on the web
and the page component provided as an E-net page are
separated, the
same logic, such as whether to consent to login use and the actual download download logic, is
duplicated.  It was written. As the number of
uses increased due to the increase in duplicate code,
dormant errors such as omission of change rights naturally
increased.
Also,
since most of the business logic was handled in the component container component, the more complex this function becomes, the more
complex the component becomes.  The size has grown and the
code has become difficult to understand.
This increasingly large problem. We
decided to reorganize the project design from the beginning.
How did we solve the design?
First, the following were considered before design.
Business
logic should be reused.  It had to be able to be done, it
had to be a structure that could be assembled without brevity between the UI and business logic, and
duplicate code had to be minimized.
dry is one of the software development principles and
is an abbreviation for uself. The
next flow is the final designed
structure.
Unlike before, it has layers.  You can see that it is one person. I
will introduce the background of this design one by one according to the flow and show this flow again at the end.
Then, let's look at it one by one.
To explain the smooth flow, the
video streaming service is as follows.  Let's
assume that it is provided.
First of all, we need to analyze UI elements.
In the service,
there may be UI elements such as logo, subscription button, SOGO button, and video chat, as follows. A
structure that allows these separate elements to be reused is also needed.  I thought so. Have you
heard of atomic design? If you've
heard of it, yes,
many people know about it, but
there may also be people who are hearing it for the first time. Atomic
design is based on an
organic structure that combines step by step, as you can see from the name Atom Walkill.
This
is a design system. Because we were focusing on this kind of reusability, we
structured the UI components using the atomic design. Going back
to the example, the
smallest elements are made into
UI components such as text, text buttons, icons, and buttons.  You can
create a logo or chat that can be assembled by assembling them, and
at the next level, you
can configure a chat list or video that can be used by assembling them. You
can configure a page with a UI that is structured in stages like this.
We provide UI  I wanted the components to
be provided in a completely separate state from the business organization.
In fact, when the
UI components are configured without affecting the server data, by
using something called a storybook,
UI tests and scores are possible even without actual data, and
UI development and  The influence between individual scripts
can be reduced.
Since storybooks can be distributed separately, there
is also the advantage of showing UI results even if the actual function is not implemented. In
order to separate the UI component from the function, it now has a feature to connect to this function.  We
created a shell quantum component called a component.
This feature component
can perform the actual necessary functions and
refer to the typical state managed by the state management live. When
this evening state is referenced in the UI component, it is
now separated from the server data.
Because it didn't work properly, we
worked so that the UI component could only receive the state that can be expressed by the actual UI component.
Among the features seen in the previous structure, the feature component plays a role similar to the container component. The
difference from the previous structure is that it is actually Business
Logic.  This is layered and separated. Let's
go back to the example and think about implementing a function called channel subscription.
In this way, the feature component
has an execution subscription,
has a subscription function, and
references the necessary data.
A layer to implement the subscription function.  We
will put it at a disadvantage. We
considered this separated layer based on user behavior and ordered it as an action layer. If you
think about the logic required to perform the act of subscribing, there
may be subscribing and unsubscribing.
What steps are needed to implement subscribing?  Do you think it's the same? I
think I'll check the login first.
Based on the logged in user for the log, if you're logged in,
subscribe. If you're
not logged in, I'll
send you a login page and run the subscription the next time you come back.
Here's a thought. I
think this login check function will be needed in many functions, even if it's not a subscription function. For example,
in the example I showed you earlier, the chat
function
would likely need a login check.
If all the logic, including login, is
If you implement it in the subscribe action layer, you will
not be able to use the login function in other action layers.
In order to use the same logic,
duplicate code may be created as follows.
To prevent this kind of military code, we also need to add business logic.
I separated one more layer to write.
This is the service layer. The
service layer separates the actual subscription-related
logic and
login-related logic into each service.
These services are
declared because of the logic of interest.
In fact, the service layer is as follows.
Following the same principle,
service logic
should be able to focus on only one role and is responsible for
processing asynchronous logic or updating the evening state.
Then, the section where this service logic must be executed again
becomes the action layer I mentioned earlier.
Using the service layer to be declared, the action layer
can be used as a single function by assembling services to perform complex functions. Also,
when calling the actual function in the future component, this action layer is called and connection is
provided.
In a feature component, you
can use the same function at the same time by simply taking the function declared in the action and calling it. If
you want to use the function even if it is a different cup UI component, you can now use the same function by taking an
action that matches the function in the feature component and telling it to
move.  Let's
talk about the structure explained so far again.
As I showed you earlier, the structure is as follows. A
user action is received from a component, a
business is
executed through this action, and it is
reflected in the store through the business logic and then again.  We deliver it to the component.
Then, the UI will change depending on what we do. If you
look in the middle of the component box, you can see that a layer called content
layer content component
has been added.
That layer is only used as a
future component during the actual implementation.  If
you have it, there are cases where the functions are mixed or like
this, so I
layered it once more to separate the functions. If you
configure the layers as needed, you
can reset and assemble them and
create a project without duplicate code.
In fact, it is a component.
Even if the function is changed or new, the function is
named in the action layer and service layer,
so if the function is already implemented,
one function is completed just by assembling it. The
first structural problem has now been solved. The
second problem is
In fact, we
originally had an existing service, but
only one such service
was considered, so the
structure did not consider the increase at all. There was
no explanation, so we said that we would separately provide the 2020 and 2022 versions of the video streaming service that was used as an example.  Let's
make an assumption.
Now, we are in a situation where our product needs to have slightly different
functions and be provided at the same time.
Previously, it
was a structure that was not considered at all for one service, so
unless resources are passed on, it can no longer be
used like this on other pages.  It was difficult, and
even if it was actually implemented with the same resources, the following branch statements would be required to
respond to these domain specifications. If you try to
respond to these requirements for each service, the number of
management points will
increase as the service increases, and the operation level of the internal logic will also
increase.  It
would be difficult to find out the specifications at a glance.
So how could we provide multiple services
at once?
Yes, we had to consider the following points before solving the problem.
Now, our services
can respond to different requirements.  We
had to
eliminate dependency on specific services, and
we needed a structure that could easily provide multiple services. To meet these points, we
decided to modularize the product.
Modular products
use computers to determine where they will be used or whether they will be used.  It
was defined so that it can be injected from custom values. In
order to provide compilation of parts that require custom and to respond to requirements,
feature flags can be set from a functional perspective.
Additionally, it can be
shaken so that it can operate depending on the situation in each use case.  We
also provide a computer in the form of the
JS Comp Korea
2020 and JS Comp Korea
2022 logos mentioned in the previous examples. You
can adjust the configuration according to different requirements as follows. You can
also configure the elements to be used through feature flags.  You
can decide.
In 2020, we declared that only the subscribe button will be used.
In 2022, you may prefer to use the title area and profile
area and not use the subscribe button.
In fact, inside the module, it is
based on the feature flag injected into the config.
By creating a hoc, you are controlling whether or not to use the component.
Then, just by using the future flag, the
component can control whether to use that component or not. By
providing configurable options in this way, you can use the module appropriate for each service.  In the
2020 page that was given as an example earlier, the
text and
logo colors were customized and only the subscription button was defined to be
used. The
2020 page
was set to change the logo and use the title and profile.
Now, you can use one module to create multiple settings.  We are now
able to respond to the service.
In order to easily provide this function,
we also provide a separate page called the management tool.
Now,
within that module, the set compact value of the management tool
is brought in by the family through server communication.
This
dynamically.  Once you can bring it in, if a
problem actually occurs, you
can respond immediately by turning off the future flag. Even
if a new feature is added, you can
deploy it first without considering the deployment order.
In fact, the service can provide
Depending on the provider, the options that must be provided
may need to be adjusted.
Since the pages we provide are provided by an internal service, we actually provide the service by
utilizing the internal service fee module. The
overall structure, including the flow and module structure mentioned earlier,  Let's summarize. The
overall project is actually composed of a monorepo
because there is not just one drawing we provide.
Now, there is a third area that collects elements
commonly used in each page.
This area
can be shared across multiple domains.
UI and business organization components that can be used are in
place.
Using these, they are assembled with the functions of each domain to
form a page and are
provided. Currently, the viewing area is
provided in the form of this module.
In fact, this structural improvement can
help maintain work-life balance.
I will share a review of whether we were able to
do it. This is the result of prototyping with our project. It
took less than a day to create different layout pages. In addition, we
can respond to various requirements from various services with just the settings as follows.
Now you no longer need to be afraid of increased services. If
you consider this scalable design, you
can increase productivity by changing the existing logic even when doing new work, and reduce redundant code to
prevent human error and
actually implement functions.  You can now focus only on one page.
Flexible response is possible at any time even if a separate page is needed. The
structure has been greatly improved from the previous structure. The
following table is a table that
I created by compiling the advantages that our team felt after changing to this structure.
In the case of our team, the
UI developer and
script developer are separated.
So, now that the UI is
separated, you
can see in the table below that it has become very convenient for those working on actual UI development.  It takes
a lot of time to design it, but as
time
goes by, this design will shine. If you
organize the project without worrying about this, you
can provide it very quickly in the beginning. As the
service grows and the number of situations that need to be responded to increases,
the time for maintenance becomes longer.  This will be
added further.
We were in a similar situation, so we improved the structure like this.
Yes, I'm not saying you should spend a lot of time on design, but I
think it will definitely be helpful if you think about it. The
testimonies of the people I work with and myself  I
introduced you to the benefits I experienced. The topic I wanted to talk about today
was the wall label. How did you like it? Thank you.
I think that by separating the UI and functions,
reusability has improved, and by
actually turning off the function, it
has become possible to respond as a platform.
Now, the same  Even when we receive requests, we have a structure that allows us to
respond very quickly compared to the previous structure. As for
our project,
many
structural and
performance improvements were made at the same time while preparing for the presentation. It is
very unfortunate that we cannot introduce them all.
Better methods and designs.  I
have some points about performance. If you do
n't hesitate to ask me about those later, I
will discuss them with you.
And the
design method I shared today is not the right answer. The
right design is different for each project.
In the case of a small project, it is like this.  A large
layering structure can actually be toxic.
In this way, the design suitable for each service
can go in a better direction through individual discussion, and now that my team is
providing a rather large service, I have
experience in layering suitable for such a large service in
this position.  It was shared in.
If we think about design like this not only in our project but also in other projects, we
can actually contribute to the development of our JavaScript world. Yes, I
will conclude today's presentation on the theme of design in terms of scalability.  Those of
you who have had similar concerns
or
would like to have similar concerns, or
who would like to give me another insight, are welcome to speak to me through the microphone at any time. Thank
you.
[Applause]